coin des avenues parole autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de l'udc qui me
demande à qui est parti ou à partir
toujours le territoire de l'île de
montréal luc ta question est super bonne
parce que on parle beaucoup de
reconnaissance de territoire 7 ans si on
veut savoir quel est l'impact d'une
reconnaissance de territoire est ce que
c'est des mots en l'air du geste
symbolique il ya le fait que les
territoires appartient à quelqu'un ce
concept là c'est quand même très
difficile à pouvoir l'expliquer en deux
nations qui ont des concepts totalement
différent l'appartenance à dans les
quatre petits poteaux plantés au coin du
terrain avec un titre de propriété
c'est un concept très européen qui est
arrivé et qui a pris place par dessus
sur le concept de on appartient au
territoire
et quand on reconnaît le territoire ça
doit faire présentement on reconnaît que
c'est le territoire mohawk on t'a
territoire non céder donc on n'a pas
donné le territoire ou the rope et quand
ils sont arrivés on reconnaît pas dans
l'appartenance du territoire comme la
propriété du territoire tant que la
responsabilité de la gestion du
territoire
et ça c'est de reconnaître que de tout
les peuples qui partagent ce territoire
là parce que montréal était quand même
une terre de partage où plusieurs
nations ont aussi reculé
et présentement on reconnaît que les
mots qui sont autour de l'île de
montréal sont ceux qui avaient les
meilleurs points de vue pour pouvoir
gérer le territoire et le faire
respecter
mais présentement je pense que si on
parle juste de reconnaissance de
territoire on va reconnaître surtout
qu'ils n'ont été n'ont pas été cédés
donc présentement on parle d'une
occupation illégale de l'île de montréal
parce qu'on la partage avec des titres
de propriété parce qu'on ne laisse pas
les morts avoir leur mot à dire sur la
gestion du territoire et de souvent
cette parole n est pas écoutés mais de
plus en plus avec les actes de
réconciliation on voit une réapparition
justement de cette reconnaissance
j'estime de gestionnaires du territoire
là on voit l'apparition du pain blanc
sur le drapeau de montréal
on voit de plus en plus d'aînés qui
viennent justement lors de rencontres
très officielle à la ville de montréal
donc je pense que malgré les
imperfections que cette participation ne
peut avoir ça reste quand même qu'il ya
un changement dans la gestion la
cogestion du territoire et elle a écrit
de plus en plus les morte pour ce qui
est de l'île de montréal
il va reconnaître aussi les algonquins
pour avoir été des habitants pour les
abénakis aussi et beaucoup d'autres
nations qui passe donc merci beaucoup
pour la question j'espère que ça n'a pu
répondre à toute interrogation vous avez
sur le réel mais je pense que c'est très
bien d'en parler avec mémoire qui
pourrait bien plus vous en parlais que
moi et c'était pas à nous partager les
vidéos et c'était pas à nous envoyer vos
questions